foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
happy National Championship day shout
out to bowling and Bryson I've got my
guys with me today we are here to build
a parlay for the national championship
but that includes you too because we're
going to use the chat to help decide
what we'll be betting on but before we
do that guys I've got a very special
guest I've got the man with the record
for the largest payout in sports betting
history 75 million and he happens to
have 9 million riding on TCU tonight he
really needs no introduction but I did
it anyway I've got the one and only
mattress Mac here sitting right by me
how's it going Mac how you feeling
everything's good Natalie I'm Feeling
Good Feeling Lucky go frog this feeling
lucky that's the word well welcome back
to this show thanks again for coming by
I want to talk to you about your TCU
bets you've got most of it on the money
line rather than the spread why are you
so confident in frogs well I think the
frogs are a team of pedestria they've
won many many games this week late in
the fourth quarter over time so I'm a
huge frog fan I grew up in Dallas Fort
Worth I played football Universe sex had
always been admire of TCU and they've
really got it going and I think it's
their team of Destiny what are they 201
in the uh summertime line to win so
biggest upset in the sports history may
be coming up tonight well we want to
make sure that everyone in the audience
drops your locks in the chat whether you
agree with mac and the frogs or not we
want to hear what you have to say but
Mac let's get to the question that is on
everyone's mind we know you're a
confident in TCU 9 million on the line
if TCU goes up early would you hedge no
it never is no
we're gonna play it out to the end they
want me to hit the astross
in no way we love to hear that never
hedge bowling Bryson what do we have in
the chat any questions for Matt coming
up I'll ask you this one in the meantime
while we get in the chat Mac what would
this mean to Texans you mentioned 200 to
one preseason you've had a lot of sales
from the Dallas area what would it mean
to the people it'd be great you know a
Texas team has never won the National
Championship in the new format I think
last Texas didn't win the national
championship was Texas Vince Young in
2005. so all Texans are pulling for TC
you're saying go frogs and we think
tonight's going to be a big night for
the frogs out in California
oh yeah we've got the frogs up already
you guys what does the chat have to say
any early questions if not Bryson I know
you had a bet you maybe want to talk to
Mack about what you got
yeah I'm gonna jump in
no no I was gonna say there's some love
in the chat we got James chrysara saying
TCU money line for the win we got that
Padres fan saying we love you Mac
um somebody's saying Max legendary
um looks like everybody's kind of online
with you man and I honestly I'm a
Michigan fan so I was sad to see TCU
lose or TCU win but I'm backing you
tonight Max so let's get it done glad to
hear that hopefully we're all going to
be happy about 10 30 central time
tonight amen
Bryson anything
yeah Mac I got something for you man Mac
I know you and I some people don't know
this a lot of people know this though
you and I were in Vegas at 3am place a
million dollar bets at the Bellagio and
I feel like that's a special bond we
have between us and not everyone else
gets to share with you and so I want
your like your uh your words of wisdom
or your support on this bet that I have
tonight first off Max Duggan to score a
touchdown the sports books have it at
plus 120 easiest bet in the world TC is
quarterback we're hitting this right
absolutely I love Max Duggan I think
he's the key to the game tonight him
scoring the first touchdown of all four
he said even first time
I like that too
I think that Max Duggan first TD that's
some good value we might have to sneak
that in the far away what you think
that's that's a Sprinkle situation then
the second one here Mac and bear with me
for a second TCU to call the first time
out tonight okay it's minus 120 and it's
a situation hey hear me out George
hasn't called the first time out in
three months you think about it new
environment TCU with a college football
player for the first time feels like a
first time out situation
that I can't comment on that one
timeouts aren't my happy thing see she's
going to first touchdown to be where I'd
be at
yeah that's a little too obscure Bryson
maybe wait for the Super Bowl for The
Crazy Ones like the Gatorade color first
time out but all in on the frogs over
here bowling anything else from the chat
before we send Mac off and bring him
back yeah actually got a really fun
comment from Eclipse saying he bought a
mattress yesterday let's go TCU so
that's really fun
um we got a lot of supporters for you
Max Duggan let's go Mac is the man tcu's
got it gangsta Mac for the dub I guess
they're in reference to your purple
Lamborghini uh hype video which made
waves in our apps so the app Community
is definitely in favor of you tonight
we love to hear that Mac we love that
video too you told me it was your son's
idea yeah my son's idea had me put on
that uh mink coat and that uh hat chain
all that and get on that purple
Lamborghini so I wish I was 18 years old
but it was still a lot of fun to do that
video well thanks so much so much for
talking to us
now in the comments saying tcu's colors
are purple so if TCU wins tonight how
about carrying some purple mattresses at
Gallery Furniture
if TCU is not will consider those purple
matches if I'm wearing my purple horn
frog outfit while I'm selling those
Tempur-Pedic mattresses all right
so who knows but Max thanks again for
joining us we're going to bring you back
in a few minutes to grade some bets from
the chat you bet very fun thank you see
you in a few
all right guys I'm actually really
looking forward to that I kind of want a
purple mattress so as if I needed
another reason to root for the frogs
we've got one but for everybody out
there in the chat as promised we're
putting together a little lay fellas
right going what three legs is that the
plan
yeah three legs I think we need some
help from our friends in the audience
but listen that's the first time we're
doing this I think that we've got a
great opportunity with a lot of high
high activity High star players in this
game like we could put together a
three-leg lock here
we do and I'm I'm looking at the chat
right now I'm waiting to see anything
that the people want in our parlay but
I'm with you
let's talk about is there anyone that is
with us on dug in anytime TD because I
think that might be a good place to
start Bryson
yes it did it is it doesn't matter who
you think's gonna win this game today
all that you need to know is Max Duggan
is finding a way to cross that line with
the ball is handsome one through the air
with his feet diving somersault whatever
it is that's the easiest better than
that hear me out though I like this bet
but part of me is
and he throws himself around that I'm a
little worried
yeah that's a great point I mean his his
game in the Big 12 Championship was
unbelievable almost single-handedly just
like bringing that team back from being
down and then he took a beating I think
in that Michigan game but one thing I
know about him and the way he's
performed over the last month is he's
just a gamer so whatever Nicks and
bruises he's got he ain't gonna feel any
of that once they kick that ball off
I agree with you I think he's got a lot
of will to win so let's see if what we
got in the chat I think someone just
said max dug in TD so I I'm guessing
they're going anytime that was DMACC
I like that spice Zibby 326. do we go I
mean Max said Duggan first TV is that a
little too much for us
too much in a three leg Yeah I'm not
enough to see that's where I I have a
losing record
yeah I'm here and I'm seeing TCU team
total over 23 and a half I think that's
one that's pretty interesting especially
given the fact that you know the over
under in the game 63 and a half points
and maybe more at this point so we're
expecting that they're gonna get at
least close to 25
I think that's a pretty good one
for a team that comes
I'll see I I mean Natalie you and I were
at the Peach Bowl that Georgia defense
couldn't stop me and you I mean they
they were not very good I I don't I
don't see any way that uh dcu's offense
like in worst case scenario they really
do get destroyed and then it's like
they're down 30 and just scoring useless
points
um I actually do like TCU team total but
I will say I will say love mattress Mac
with all my heart but there's a lot of
just Pro TCU stuff getting spammed into
this chat spammed into this parlay and I
do think we need to remember there's a
team that's like a 13 and a half Point
favorite and uh probably gonna win this
game
um tonight so just saying I don't want
to get too far K away with all this Pro
uh TCU stuff
so I see it's not right now and I see
that is that what you want to say
bowling I was just gonna say that we
were on the same page you and I met
because there is a lot of love for
Georgia I'm seeing Macintosh over 6 and
65 and a half rush yards Mal coming back
in over 21 and a half receiving yards
for Macintosh I think that's gone up a
little bit he made a really good point
in the app this morning they played 335
defense and it's going to be hard to
contain some of those bruising running
backs so maybe we look towards Macintosh
maybe is over rushing maybe is over
receiving could be good
I also see in here just instead of
taking team total over just straight up
going with the over Anthony Marciano
said over 63 and a half could be the
play I don't know I like that too I feel
a different uh you guys know I'm Pro TCU
I've got the purple jacket on I think
everyone's counted them out all year I
think they'll find a way to go over
their team total but taking the over is
also not a bad play I don't know if if
we like one more than the other there
well I think the I think the idea here
is if we're gonna do a parlay we already
know that Max got all the money on TCU
money line and TCU spread so why don't
we just like lock in the team total and
hope for a big night from uh from the
Horned Frogs
I like that because Bryson we were in
the car just like you said the first bet
we mentioned was the team total over for
this game
all right cool okay what else do you
guys see in the chat I think some people
agree with us it is so Pro TCU though
I'm getting a little concerned
all right so it looks like it looks like
we're gonna have trouble with the team
total I'm not sure
um if you want to click into oh maybe we
can't parlay it okay well that's fine I
think Max Duggan is a good place to
start we're all aligned on that
obviously we can I think I think we can
I think we're just not on the SGP
options I think that was the problem we
had I might be wrong but I don't think
either way I mean I love Max Duggan as
an anytime touchdown scorer here and
maybe if we can get some more if we can
get some more action on that total maybe
it is the the game total I really just
feel like there's going to be a ton of
points in this game both semi-final
games went flying over and I think
tonight we're going to see a lot of the
same
the second leg if not I like the over in
general too speaking of the over we have
S Peko said Bowers over everything I
don't know if we want to add some some
UGA Spice in here we're pretty you know
Pro TC right now but what are our
thoughts there
is one of the best players in the
country I mean I think the only thing
that we have to really worry about is
hopefully no one gets hurt like he's a
monster and he I definitely think will
be one of the first Titans taken in the
draft when he comes up so
if you really can't go wrong go betting
on Brock Bowers you guys witnessed that
in person
if we want to keep you though Quinn
Johnson Bryson you were telling me
earlier and I see some people in the
chat right now talking about him he's a
star he's gonna have a great game you
would assume
foreign yeah no I I agree I'll say you
know I'm not one to discriminate on legs
of parlays I in my opinion four is
better than three like in my opinion
this is just my opinion you know Quinn
Johnston 70 plus yards Brock Bower is 50
plus yards
that's all I gotta say
s let's see what the chat thinks about
Quinn Johnson
someone mentioned his over-receptions I
actually might like that better than
over yards what do you guys think is
that one that we could add in here
I agree but we cannot in the same game
parlay so that so that is our problem
well just for analysis sake like he is
going to get a lie and share of these
targets like if you've watched any TCU
games this year he is their go-to guy on
the outside and a match-up nightmare for
a lot of teams the only difference is
while George's DBS aren't great they're
big they're tall they're fast they're
physical so they could present some
some defensive pushback that I don't
know if he's seen either way he's gonna
get his though that's for sure
I agree I see someone else said
Macintosh in here Bowers over 50 plus
receiving yards just throwing out some
options that we have
over 24 and a half receiving yards now
all right we're back in fellas we're
back in all right now we got it all
right so we're we're on Duggan we're a
line there we're on the team total over
24 and a half do we want to tease it
down a little bit
yeah I think 23 and a half is the right
spot to get go to effective team scoring
back to team scoring
team scoring team scoring and scroll
down there we go yeah keep going down
keep going going down keep going down
there we go there we go
I like teasing it down a little bit too
smart well you got to just consider the
three numbers right 24 and a half puts
you in a hole if they end up with 24
points you're easier to get 24 than 20
obviously than 25
um when you think about kicking field
goals and all that so 23 and a half
looks good yeah and also delete Max
Duggan you need to reselect Max Duggan
once you've uh clicked SGP so just
delete Max diving and go pick them again
at least the chat
I was gonna say at least the chat is not
confused that we are putting it together
we have the magic producer behind the
lens who's obviously struggling a little
bit but we love them anyway we're here
yeah
producer Max
okay wait I gotta I got a question I got
a comment in the uh chat why are y'all
betting on the QB to score face palm I
guess he hasn't watched much of TCU
because that dude's a hammer yeah on the
goal line
I wonder
do we listen or do we feel like we need
to make a change no
not what
dude if you watch TCU he scored a
touchdown like five out of the last six
games and the one that he didn't he
didn't need to foreign
I think we should look for that last leg
and I want to revisit Quinton Johnson
what is the chat thing I need y'all to
get in the chat and let me know because
it just seems like taking one of his
props is just too easy and maybe that's
you know my betting radar tends to be
off but I think that he could be a great
final leg in our parlay what do you guys
think and I'm gonna look in the chat and
see if anybody else is with me or not
so it looks like we do have support for
Quentin Johnson Anthony Marciano coming
into our defense yeah Duggan runs a lot
we definitely watch
um I do think that Kenny McIntosh is a
leg that we need to enter into here so
we're not completely all on TCU so
Bryson this is your time to shine we
said it was a three leg
we're gonna make it a four leg it sounds
like
that's I agree I like honestly this is
just my take again just give and takes
Kenny McIntosh 50 plus
and then you go Quinn Johnson 70 plus
there we go well Mal agrees he says make
it four legs and add Kenny Mack this is
really interesting I do I do really like
the receiving yards and I also like his
rushing yards so if you say 50 there's
no way this game ends and he doesn't
have 50 rushing yards that's just really
how I feel
I agree I have an actual statement not a
lie was said so are we turning this into
a four leg or those before that we're
going with
Yeah well yeah we need to uh we're going
QJ right or Quinn Johnson right yeah it
looks like we got a lot of support
yep
get them at 70 receiving
your tea out in my man's name by the way
Quinn Johnson no I said Johnston I said
put back in there
there we go look well we got a six six
plus six twenty five parlay
I like it a lot
I like it too all right what's the final
price here let's let's see 625
6 25
. all right you guys
we got Mal saying he's good with it we
got Benny flan saying have fun losing
money tonight folks it's really
interesting because we're all going to
be hanging out at the cashier tonight so
uh you're not getting a ride
um who else
Marciano really likes it he said 80 over
80 and over on catches so we teased it
down a little bit this feels like it
can't miss I don't know about I don't
know what you guys think but I'm
counting my money early this is hitting
I agreement
confidence check Bryson before you wrap
this one up what do you think this one
hitting at the at the end of the day I
the only one that's like honestly scary
for me is Max Duggan and I'm not scared
about it like I I don't see a world
where TCU doesn't score 24. I don't see
Kitty McIntosh it's probably gonna run
50 yards on the first play just like
Michigan to do last week and then
putting Johnston like he's gonna get two
or three catches that are like at the
sticks and then he's probably going to
absolutely Moss somebody from Georgia
just like like Marvin like Georgia's
defense is good dude all respect to the
world Marvin Harrison was unguardable
until you got hurt again so like they're
defense and also dude don't get me
started on what LSU's backup quarterback
did to them in the SEC Championship Game
the defense is overrated I went to
Kansas we would probably be Georgia
that's all I have to say oh my God
that's like all right we let him go on
his rant we kept it on him a minute too
long ago we're gonna wrap it there those
are our four legs of the parlay over 23
and a half TCU team total Max Duggan
anytime TV scorer Kitty McIntosh over 49
and a half rushing yards and Quentin
Johnson over 69 and a half receiving
yards that's delay plus 625 see you guys
at the cashier and you mentioned Bryson
you were a little iffy about that Max
Duggan bet we're about to bring someone
back it was not iffy about Duggan
getting back in the end zone at all so
that's right we're bringing mac back
he's coming back in here right now so if
you're in the audience and you want him
to grade your bet drop it in the chat
because once again we've got the man
sitting by us and he's gonna grade your
pick so Mac for this one we're gonna go
abcdf and if you really don't like it we
can go f minus so let's see what we have
bowling Bryson any early ones in here
yeah I think we should stay on the trend
of Max Duggan uh dollar Jones asking
over rush yards for Max Duggan I don't
have the number in front of me but I'm
assuming he just means whatever number
it is he's gonna rush for all of those
yards so how do you feel about the over
on Max Doug and rush yards tonight Mac I
love Max Duggan so I got to go to the
over I agree with that one that's it hey
all right we're going a for Max Doug and
being a mobile QB tonight Bryson
anything sticking out to you in the chat
what do we got
yeah nobody's really given anything at
least that I'm seen yet on the chat but
I I'm curious your opinion
um Mac going back you know to the
rushing touchdown you know for for Max
Duggan like in your opinion how do you
see Max Duggan's first touchdown playing
out tonight
about a seven yard run they get down to
uh in the Red Zone he runs seven yards
runs it in I think Max duck is a huge
factor in this game as our both
quarterbacks but I'm a Max Duggan fan
how can you not be he has so much I'm
I'm with Mac there I'm gonna sprinkle
first TD score Mac so I like that but
nobody else was with me on that I get it
can't put it in a parlay
whatever I got enough I got another
question for you Mac
um Moody baby wants to know how do you
choose your bets
a lot of has to do with the money line
and I thought that when the money line
came out for TCU at plus 440 I thought
that was way invited because uh George
is a great team in TCU is kind of a
newcomer to this game so that was that
what's made me decide to do this
promotion for this bet was taking the
money line on TCU because a lot of
Leverage there and a lot of value
um
oh yeah Bryson go ahead what you got
yeah Michael A lot of people are asking
your opinion on taking the over tonight
it's 62 and a half 63 kind of depends
there what's your opinion there
I love the over it's raining in Los
Angeles but it's a great dome stadium
and I think the both teams are going to
light it up that's been their uh the
history of TCU and they run fast fast
offense I think they'll score a lot of
points and uh my prediction is 41-37
frogs so hopefully it'll come true
yeah
you heard it a lot of points so I think
this goes along with that I got one in
the chat right now over 23 and a half
points Moody baby said his Mac like
tcu's team total over I'm just what do
you absolutely like t-shirt came out
over it over 23 and a half I wish I was
in a legal betting State though we bet a
lot of these parlays myself oh yeah he
said
Mack that's really funny because the
amount you bet and all the the good work
you do that you would think they'd just
make it legal just because of you
and I told him it probably shouldn't
make it legal because I bet too much
that I have a little restraint on me
having to go to Louisiana
see that's that's how I feel too all
right so somebody we'll do a bonus
question somebody said something about
the Astros maybe we can rap with this
one mattress Mac do you already have an
Astros 2023 World Series future bet
already ghostros from John S I'm a huge
Astros fan we're already running an
Astros promotion I've got some bets
coming up after I get through these
football bets so I'll be betting heavy
on The Strokes to repeat as World Series
champions in 2023 ghostro is what a
great team been in the ml uh air
American League championship series six
out of the last six years uh a Friday
one for the Houston Astros oh yeah
ghostros for mac and and Go Frogs today
Max Go Frogs that's it we're doing
purple today not orange and blue purple
okay let's review it we can pull that
one up for the people
and I don't know about you guys but I
hate to use the word lock but it just
feels like it's gotta be a lock right
I have no reason to believe that this
bet isn't gonna hit listen we we're
using our brains right we've watched the
games all the games that these guys have
played over the last couple weeks and
months Max Duggan has found the end zone
all the time Bryson mentioned that all
these games have gone over all the
receivers are going over and the running
backs have had hell of running games
there's no reason why this doesn't hit
and it's six to one value
we're all getting new we're all getting
new watches tomorrow it sounds like
yeah you can't beat it I'm feeling
pretty good about it you guys I think
that again if I lived in a legal betting
state or I was an illegal state right
now I'm going to DK and I'm putting in
Max exact score bet and I'm doing Duggan
for CPA so that's why it's a good thing
I'm in Houston Texas but let's review
real quick once again for the people in
the chat we've got four leg parlay we
couldn't help ourselves we had to add
one more TCU team total over Max Duggan
getting in the end zone Macintosh
getting over 49 and a half rushing yards
and Quentin Johnson over 69 and a half
receiving yards that'll pay about six to
one plus 625 on that parlay all right
fellas I really enjoy putting this
together I think there's no way I'm not
going to the cashier so thank you guys
for joining me we'll be here watching
the game with Mac tonight so make sure
to follow us in the app and on social
but until then we'll see you guys next
time
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]